WHAT TABLE YOU GUYS
SIT AT?
- JEFF WAS A REFEREE
IN THE NBA.
- EXACTLY, THAT'S A CARRY.
WE'RE GOING THAT WAY.
WHAT ARE WE DOING?
WE DOING HANDS IN PANTS?
IS THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING?
LOVE THE KID 'N PLAY MOVIES.
I LOVE THOSE KID 'N PLAY MOVIES.
THOSE GUYS? SHOO.
THEY EVER BEEN IN HERE?
YOU GUYS LIKE A DUO?
YOU LOOKING FOR
THREE MUSKETEERS OR ANYTHING?
TWO-TO-ONE SAYS I SIT
WITH YOU GUYS
AND IT'S TATER TOTS
FOR LUNCH.
HEY, CROSBY, STILLS,
YOU LOOKING FOR A NASH?
RIGHT.
- WITH NOWHERE TO SIT...
- YOU GUYS HANGING? NO?
- JEFF NEEDS
TO ASSERT HIMSELF...
- [drops tray on table]
- OR RISK BECOMING A TARGET.
- [blows whistle]
FINE!
I'LL BE YOUR ENEMY!
BUT THE THING I'LL YOU
IS I WILL BE DOWNSTAIRS
IN THE TV ROOM
THIS AFTERNOON,
AND YOU CAN DO WHATEVER YOU WANT
AT THAT POINT.
YOU COULD THINK
ABOUT YOUR GIRLFRIEND AT HOME.
YOU WANT IT TO BE SWEET?
SOUTHERN BELLE?
[soft voice]
WELL, I NEVER!
[normal voice]
I'LL DO THAT ALL DAY.
BUT YOU GOTTA COME DOWN
TO THE TV ROOM,
'CAUSE I'M NOT
COMING TO YOU.
UNLESS YOU WANT ME
TO COME TO YOU, I WILL.
YEAH, I'M NOT SURE IF I'M GONNA
BE A TOP OR A BOTTOM.
I GUESS I'LL, YOU KNOW,
WHEN--WHEN THE GUYS SHOW UP.
- NO ONE ACCEPTS
JEFF'S INVITATION.
- SEEMS LIKE SOME OF THE GUYS
IN THE YARD
ARE GIVING ME
THE COLD SHOULDER, BUT--
[louder] SEEMS LIKE SOME OF
OF THE GUYS IN THE YARD
ARE GIVING ME
THE COLD SHOULDER.
- YOU'LL GET THROUGH IT.
I DID.
- [chuckles]
OH, IT'S GOOD TO HAVE
A FRIEND.
- MORE OF A CELLMATE.
- YEAH.
CELLMATES DON'T TALK
LIKE THIS.
- I'M OUT IN A MONTH.
I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE
MY BEAUTIFUL GIRLS.
- YOU'RE A FAM--UNH.
[defecating]
YOU'RE A FAMILY MAN, HUH?
[toilet flushes]
FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE,
IT'S LIKE I'VE BEEN IN SOLITARY,
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN,
YOU KNOW,
I GOT A GROUP OF GUYS
THAT I CAN CONNECT WITH.
WE'RE LOCKED IN HERE TOGETHER.
THERE'S NO ESCAPING.
MAURICE, I HAD A DREAM
THAT YOU WOULDN'T BELIEVE.
I GUESS I'LL HAVE TO TELL YOU
THE WHOLE THING
START TO FINISH.
[somber music]
♪
MAURICE?
GUARDS!
SOMEBODY BROKE INTO MY CELL
AND HUNG MY BEST FRIEND
LAST NIGHT.
- JEFF HAS LOST
HIS ONLY FRIEND.
- DON'T WORRY, MAURICE.
- MAKING ANOTHER
WILL BE THE KEY TO HIS SURVIVAL.
- WHO AM I GONNA
SIT WITH AT LUNCH?
IS HE GONE?
- SHUT UP.